what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will be breaking down the full tragic
and inspirational backstories of all the
hashira in the demon slayer story the
hashira are some of the strongest and
most epic characters in the entire
series and to a large extent their
backstories made these characters into
who they are today now you will have
everything you need to know about all
their backstories right here in one
place so let's get into it if you guys
enjoy our demonstrate content and you
want to see more in the future just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
the youtube algorithm and if you're new
to the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications a quick
thank you to the likewise app for
sponsoring this video likewise is an
incredibly useful app that takes all the
hassle out of finding great anime movie
tv and book recommendations instead of
wasting your time googling
recommendations and then trying to
figure out where you can actually watch
them just get the likewise app for free
powered by a combination of smart
technology and recommendations from real
people the likewise app will give you
the best recommendations quickly all you
have to do is tell the app the genres
and titles you enjoy and likewise gives
you personalized recommendations they
also show you which streaming service is
streaming them their algorithm will give
you a bunch of new recommendations based
on the shows or movies or books that
you've already enjoyed including new
recommendations every single day and if
your tastes are very specific you can
just ask directly in the app there's a
group called the anime lounge that
features a ton of great anime
recommendations the other day i saw
someone asking for anime similar to
anohana so i recommended angel beats and
clanad before i knew it there were over
a dozen great recommendations on that
single post it's that easy this app is
super useful and saves a lot of time so
click that top link in the description
to download the likewise app for free
again it's 100 free so click that link
right now
finally this video will contain manga
spoilers specifically regarding the
hashida backstories i won't tell you
what happens to the hashira later on in
the story but i will tell you their past
so please be advised let's start things
off with the first hashida that we meet
in the demonstrator story giu tomioka we
meet him right in chapter one of the
manga and episode one of the anime when
he attacks demon nezuko while tanjiro is
attempting to get through to her and
calm her down giu intends to kill nezuko
as killing demons is his job but tanjiro
begs and pleads with him not to kill her
because he believes that there must be a
way to turn her back to normal after all
nezuko never consumed any human flesh so
there could still be hope for her giu
thinks that the idea of trying to turn a
demon back into a human is ridiculous
once someone becomes a demon there is no
cure for them and the only acceptable
course of action is to kill the demons
so they can't go on to hurt innocent
people in the future tanjiro then tries
to physically stop giu from hurting
nezuko but his attacks are easily dealt
with by gilu however that is when
something strange happens nezuko the
demon intervenes in order to protect her
human brother from the hashira gihu is
shocked that a demon especially one who
was turned recently would protect a
human instead of devouring them in order
to get stronger after the draining
transformation process
following a serious inner conflict giu
decides to do the unthinkable he spares
nezuko's life when first watching this
scene we don't really understand the
gravity of this decision but the more we
learn about the demonstr and the hashira
the more meaningful and surprising
geyu's decision turns out to be for a
demon slayer to spare a demon in this
way is practically unheard of and this
is even more true for a hashira when all
the hashida assemble for tanjiro and
nezuko's trial we see exactly how
disturbed they are by giu's decision
most of them want to kill nezuko
immediately and even the thought of
doing otherwise seems completely insane
to them but giul stands by his decision
and even goes so far as to promise that
he tanjiro and former hashira sakonji
urokudaki will all forfeit their lives
if nezuko ever attacks a human so what
led giu to make such an unusual decision
and to then stake his own life and the
life of his master on the outcome of
that decision after all if giu hadn't
made this decision then the whole story
of demonstrator would have been
completely different without giu's
difficult choice there would be no
demonstrator as we know it and that is
where giu's backstory comes in in
chapter 130 of the manga we get a moment
where tanjiro realizes that giu is kind
of mad at him when tanjiro asks why giu
says he's disappointed that tanjiro has
been focusing on hinokamikagura instead
of trying to perfect water breathing in
order to become the water hashira when
tanjiro says that there is already a
water hashira and that is of course gu
giu says that no there is no water
hashira right now because he is not the
water hashira kiyo doesn't want to
explain what he means by this at first
but after tanjiro keeps pushing for days
and days giu finally reveals that he
never passed his final selection well he
did technically pass but not in the way
that he would have wanted to giul
participated in the final selection
along with a boy named sabito they were
both 13 at the time and they had both
lost their families to demons they
quickly became friends but then despite
the fact that sabito was the one who
killed all the demons on that mountain
everyone but sabito passed the exam
sabito didn't pass because he was the
only one who died during that particular
final selection
giu's own performance at that final
selection was practically the opposite
of sabito giu was injured by the very
first demon that he had encountered and
that demon's attack left him in a daze
sabito then came to his rescue and he
entrusted giu to another boy before
going off to help others who were crying
out for help by the time giu recovered
from his injury the final selection was
over he technically passed because he
survived but sabito the boy who rescued
him did not survive because of this giu
doesn't consider himself to be a
legitimate hashira since he doesn't feel
like he truly passed his final selection
how could someone who hadn't even
defeated a single demon and had to be
rescued by another person say that they
passed basically giu has a sort of
imposter syndrome when it comes to the
other hashira despite being extremely
strong he doesn't consider himself to be
worthy of standing side by side with the
others he feels that the other hashira
have all earned their position but he
has not so he sees himself as an
imposter a fake water hashira and he was
hoping that tanjiru would eventually
replace him by becoming a worthy water
hashira in his death now of course
tanjiro knows sabito because he had
actually met him during training for his
own final selection well sort of
the souls of sabito and makomo who were
both killed by demons after being taken
in and trained by sakonji rokudaki
appeared on mount sagiri and they helped
prepare tanjiro for his final selection
after taking in everything that giu had
said tanjiro realizes how giu must feel
giul feels that he should have died
instead of sabito because if sabito had
lived then he would have potentially
become a much better demon slayer than
gyu tanjiro felt the same way after
rengoku died protecting him he felt that
if he had died instead of rengoku then
rangoku could have gone on to do so many
amazing things maybe even defeat muzon
once and for all but tanjiro also
remembers what inosuke had said to him
after rengoku's death rengoku believed
in them so they don't have to worry
about anything other than living up to
that tanjiro says something similar to
giu he tells him to make use of the gift
that sabito gave him by saving his life
giu then remembers an exchange he had
with sabito an exchange in which sabito
smacked him after giu had said that he
wishes he would have been killed by a
demon instead of his sister it turns out
that giu's older sister was preparing
for her wedding which was to take place
the next day but when a demon attacked
she sacrificed her own life in order to
protect gilu sabito tells giu to never
disrespect his sister's death by saying
what he just said he must stay alive
because his sister sacrificed her life
to give him a future the name of giu's
sister was tsutako tomioka and her death
was so hard on him to deal with that he
had blocked it out of his mind so this
means that giul lost two people he was
close to because they sacrificed
themselves in order to protect him no
wonder he has an inferiority complex
people kept giving up their own life to
save him but he couldn't do anything to
protect them according to the
demonstrator fan book since the
existence of demons is not public
knowledge when giu told everyone that
his sister was killed by a demon people
thought he was mentally disturbed and he
was sent away to one of his relatives
who practiced medicine giu ran away
before arriving at the relative's house
and he almost died out there in the
wilderness thankfully he was found by a
hunter who was friends with sakonji and
so gee was placed in sakonji's care the
giu gaiden extra chapters revealed that
after giu's encounter with tanjiro and
nezuko some people suspected that giu
was the one who slaughtered the kamado
family because he had been spotted in
the area again they didn't realize that
a demon did it because they don't know
that demons exist so they blamed giu i
think that giu's rough past may have
contributed to his decision to
ultimately spare nezuko's life the fact
that he feels unworthy of being a
hashira makes him less sure of himself
than a regular hashera may be and so he
is more likely to be open-minded and
second-guess himself every demon
slayer's first instinct is to kill every
demon and most hashira wouldn't think
twice about it but because giu doesn't
think highly of himself and of his own
decision-making abilities he was
open-minded enough to give nezuko a
chance and that is what set the entire
demon slayer adventure in motion
personally i think that giu has more
than earned his place as one of the
hashira and he is one of the strongest
characters in demon slayer but at the
same time i can definitely see where
he's coming from there's no way for him
to go back and redo the moment in his
life where others died to protect him
and he couldn't do anything to help them
so that is something that has stayed
with him for a long time next let's talk
about our boy the fiery chad kyojuro
rengoku kyojiro is the son of the former
flame hashira shinjuro and he takes
great pride in his duties as one of the
strongest demon slayers but even though
rengoku is the son of the former flame
hashira his father shinjuro has been
anything but supportive throughout his
childhood rengoku's father constantly
told him that he had no talent and that
he would never become the next flame
hashira rengoku's father also drank
frequently and he could be downright
abusive to his two sons although
rengaku's mother was a much gentler
person than his father she unfortunately
died when rengoku was still quite young
although rengoku agreed with his father
that he didn't have any special natural
talents he forced himself to train hard
and become strong even though his father
kept telling him to just quit and focus
on becoming something other than a
hashida rengoku refused to listen and he
did eventually become the new flame
hashira rengoku clearly did not inherit
his father's personality because he was
always very kind and supportive of his
younger brother sandro not only did
rengoku refuse to allow his father's
constant criticism to bring him down but
he also did his best to bring other
people up including his younger brother
as a result sanjuro looked up to his
older brother and saw him as an
important source of inspiration in his
own life since sanjuro also had to deal
with their father's abuse and criticism
the fact that he could count on his
older brother's support meant a great
deal to him before she died his mother
ruka told him that as someone who is
strong rengoku has a duty to protect
those who are weaker than him and so
rengoku committed himself to saving
innocent people from the demons in a
special one-shot manga chapter that came
out after the main demonstrator manga
ended we got to see what happened during
rengoku's very first mission as a demon
player before he ever became a hashira
this early chapter of rengoku's life is
very important for understanding his
character when he is dispatched on his
first mission rengoku encounters a flute
demon who by that point had already
murdered nine of rengoku's demon slayer
comrades he had also taken the lives of
a group of children and he was about to
take the life of another child when
rengoku arrived faced with the sight of
all of those corpses rengoku was forced
to accept the tragic reality about how
fragile human life is and how cruel and
ruthless the demons can be this flute
demon is truly a monster and he has a
powerful blood demon art which makes him
almost impossible to fight basically
anyone who hears the sound of the
demon's flute has their entire nervous
system thrown out of whack so it is
impossible to move and fight properly
while hearing the sound of the demon's
flute one option for rangoku is to cover
both of his ears with his hands but if
he does that then he cannot use his
swords and if he can't use a sword then
he cannot defeat the demon so rengoku is
backed into a corner if he uses his
sword his nervous system will be
disrupted and he won't be able to fight
but if he keeps his ears covered he
still won't be able to fight because he
can't use his sword and if that wasn't
bad enough the demon is also able to use
his flute to summon deadly wolves and
these wolves are going to devour rengoku
if he doesn't find some way to fight
back the demon begins to mock rangoku
and the demon sears as a whole all of
those years of demonstrator training
have been rendered completely useless by
the effects of his flute the demon
sayers seem powerless against him but
rengoku then proceeds to do something
that cements his status as an absolute
chad and something that the flu demon
couldn't anticipate rengoku hits his own
ears so hard that he ruptures his own
eardrums this temporarily disrupts his
ability to hear which allows him to use
his sword to take the demon down rengoku
kills the demon and he saves the
innocent child whose life had been in
danger and then after that unbelievable
ordeal that he had just gone through
rengoku actually smiles he smiles
through the pain because he wants to
reassure the surviving child that
everything is going to be alright
rengaku also expresses gratitude to all
of his fallen comrades it turns out that
as they died the other demon slayers
used sign language to secretly reveal
the nature of the flu demon's power to
rengoku when rengoku arrived he saw the
message that his comrades were trying to
convey and that is how he was able to
figure out an effective strategy to take
the flute demon down rengoku vows to one
day become as admirable as his fallen
comrades
this moment and rengoku's behavior
throughout this entire mission showcases
so perfectly what kind of valiant
warrior he is he thinks outside the box
he sacrifices his own body in order to
save the innocent and he is able to
smile through the pain for the sake of
others rengoku certainly lived up to the
promise that he made to his mother the
promise to do everything to protect
those who were weaker than him just like
giu rengoku also got two extra gaiden
chapters that revealed more about his
backstory and how he earned the position
of flame hashira but because these
chapters also place a heavy focus on the
love hashira mitsuri i will talk about
them when i cover mitsuri's backstory
which is right now mitsuri kanroji is
the love hashira and she uses her own
custom breathing style called love
breathing that said love breathing is
actually a derivative of flame breathing
which you learned from rengoku i'll talk
more about that in a little bit but
first let's talk about mitsuri's early
life which greatly shaped the person
that she eventually became mitsuri was
born in a family of five children and
her entire family seems to get along
well when tanjiro first asks her why she
became a hashira she tells him that she
did it because she wanted to find a man
to marry this might sound weird at first
but once we consider mitsuri's backstory
it all starts to make sense ever since
she was very young mitsuri ate a lot
more than the average person and she
became much stronger than the average
person in fact her body itself is unique
it is much more flexible than the normal
human body and she has eight times more
muscle density than the average human as
a result mitsuru has always been
freakishly strong and because she is a
woman this strength made her an outcast
in the extremely traditional society
that she grew up in oh and her unique
hair color didn't help much either she
has pink hair which is apparently the
result of her eating too much sakura
mochi as funny as that may sound it
still made her stand out even more from
the rest of society at the age of 17
mitsuri was engaged to be married but
the arrangement was called off when her
husband-to-be decided that she was too
weird because of her hair color and
strange physique and so he said that he
didn't want to pass those genes to their
children what an absolute [ __ ] like
yeah i know this video is supposed to be
more about facts and information than my
own personal opinions but man what an
absolute [ __ ] anyway even though that
guy was a complete and utter fool this
incident had a profound effect on
mitsuri and of course we can't blame her
being rejected by her husband to be in
such a traditional society would put her
and her family in a difficult situation
so after her engagement was broken off
mitsuri decided to completely change
herself in order to fit in with the rest
of society she actually dyed her pink
hair black she pretended to be weak and
she ate much less than she needed to so
that people wouldn't be intimidated by
her massive appetite as a result she was
often so malnourished that she would
faint although the changes that she made
didn't make mitsuri fit in with the rest
of society and potential suitors became
interested in her again she just didn't
feel right she felt like she wasn't
being true to herself and that the life
she was leading was a lie
thankfully mitsuri met kagaya ubuyashiki
the leader of the demonstr also known as
oyakatasama rather than thinking that
her freakish strength made her weird
oyakatasama was amazed by it and he told
her that it was a gift from the gods
anyone who speaks ill of her talents
must just be jealous and there is
nothing wrong with a girl who is strong
in katasama and the demon slayers
mitsuri finally found true acceptance
and she was finally able to be herself
again not only that but she could use
her incredible physical talents to fight
demons and save innocent people oh and
back to the marriage question becoming a
demon sire meant that mitsuri would be
around a lot of extremely strong men so
she could finally find a man to marry
who was stronger than her so he wouldn't
be intimidated by her own strength this
plan didn't work out so well though
because mitsuri quickly advanced through
the demonstranks and became a hashira
this meant that even within the demon
slayers very few men were actually
stronger than her before she became a
hashira mitsuri was trained by kyojiro
renkoku she learned his flame breathing
style of swordsmanship but she later
modified it into her own custom style
known as love breathing love breathing
is unique because it takes full
advantage of mitsuri's special physique
including her superhuman flexibility and
incredible muscle density in the rengoku
gaiden chapters we get a glimpse of
renkoku training mitsuri and we even get
to see the moment mitsuri gets her first
official demon slayer uniform and yes it
is definitely a perfectly normal
regulation demon slayer uniform soon
after that all the hashira are summoned
by oyakatasama by this point kyojo
rengoku's father shinjuro had already
given up on being a hashira after the
death of his wife he began drinking
heavily and he lost the will to fight as
a result he refuses to answer oya
katasama's summons for all the hashira
and so kyojiro renkoku decides to go
instead of his father despite the fact
that he is still not the flame hashira
at this point in time after rengoku
expresses his desire to become the next
flame hashira at the hashira meeting
oyakatasama gives him the opportunity to
prove himself worthy by defeating lower
moon to heidel a demon who has been
threatening the capital city of tokyo
rengoku takes mitsuri on this mission
with him and this is the first mission
that they ever go on together mitsuri is
able to learn a lot from rangoku during
this battle not just in terms of
fighting but also in terms of character
rengoku is also an outcast as far as
social expectations go he also has
extremely unusual hair his clothes are
unconventional he carries a sword
everywhere he goes and so on since they
have to travel to tokyo which is full of
people rengoku gets quite a few comments
about being strange and weird and scary
but he just brushes them off in stride
and continues to smile and to do his job
this inspires mitsuri to follow in
rengoku's footsteps it is during the
fight against lower moon 2 heido that
mitsuri begins to develop her own unique
breathing style the breath of love which
was of course greatly inspired by
rengoku's flame breathing ultimately
haidou falls after an epic battle
against the burning determination of
rengoku and as a result kyojiro replaces
his father shinjuro as the flame hashira
meanwhile mitsuri has finally found a
place where she can be herself and
people that accept her for who she is
this allows her to tap into her full
potential and eventually she too becomes
a hashira since we just talked about
mitsuri let's talk about the man who is
clearly in love with her the serpent
hashira obanai iguro just like mitsuri
iguro carries a lot of personal baggage
and he has serious confidence issues in
fact he feels that he isn't worthy of
mitsuri because his bloodline is corrupt
and impure for centuries his family only
seemed to be giving birth to girls and
iguru appeared to have been the only boy
who was born into the family in like 370
years once he was born he was confined
to a prison cell where he was fond over
by his mother sisters and aunts and
brought rich foods to eat every single
day igor eventually learned that his
entire family worshipped a female demon
who was half human and half snake and he
also learned that they had been feeding
their own offspring to this demon as
sacrifices in return the demon made the
family rich by giving them the valuables
of all the other humans that she killed
because igura was born with unusual eyes
the snake demon took a liking to him and
she decided that she wouldn't eat him as
a baby instead she apparently decided
that she would wait until he was older
and fatten him up she also had his mouth
sliced so that it would more closely
resemble her own snake mouth thankfully
before he could be eaten igor managed to
escape his cell and run away the snake
demon tried to capture him but she was
killed by the former flame hashira
shinjuro rengoku who at the time was the
current flame hashira before she was
killed the snake demon took out nearly
everyone in iguoda's large family
because they failed to prevent his
escape and so igoro continued to carry
the burden of his family's sins as well
as the death of most of his family
members for his entire life he had
decided long ago that he wanted to die
defeating muzon in order to purify the
filthy blood of his family and so he
trained hard to become a demon slayer
and a hashira even though deep down he
considered himself to be weak and
unworthy but if he were to be one day
reborn as a human in a peaceful world
without demons he would then finally
confess his true feelings for mitsuri
there are a ton of interesting buddhist
and hinduist influences to igoro's
backstory including the idea of
purifying oneself karma and being
reincarnated into a better life but i
don't want to get too deeply into that
because this is already going to be a
very long video the important thing to
take away from all of this is that just
like mitsuri igor always thought of
himself as an outcast who would never be
accepted by society part of it was
because of his unconventional upbringing
part of it was the sins of his bloodline
and part of it was his physical
appearance because his face had been
scarred by the snake demon and of course
he also had those unique eyes and yet
within the demon slayer core iguru found
a place to belong he found people who
accepted him and he even found love the
demon slayers were able to recognize
true talent and potential in people who
were rejected and looked down upon by
society and that is in no small part due
to how kind compassionate and
open-minded oya katasama is
next up let's talk about the star of the
entertainment district arc the gigachad
tengen uzui tangen comes from ashinobi
or ninja family and he was one of nine
siblings his family was extremely
committed to the shinobi way of life and
three of his siblings died before they
even reached the age of 10 due to the
extreme ninja training methods that they
were put through and that is not even
the worst part the remaining six
siblings including tengan were
essentially forced to fight each other
to the death by their own father
apparently all of the siblings were made
to wear masks during the fight so they
didn't even know whom they were fighting
tan tangent only realized what was
really going on after he had already
killed two of his own brothers in the
end only tangent and one other brother
survived and while tengan's last
surviving brother accepted their
father's belief that ginobi must be
willing to commit even the harshest acts
in order to protect their clan tangent
simply could not accept this horrible
mindset he decided to abandon his clan
and he left the shinobi village of his
birth along with his three hot ninja
wives you see the uzui family practiced
polygamy and so tengen was forced to go
through an arranged marriage with three
kunuichi women who were chosen by the
head of their shinobi clan after they
left their clan tengen encouraged his
wives to completely reevaluate their
most fundamental values from a very
young age shinobi are taught to place
their clan and their mission above all
other things including their own lives
if a shinobi must sacrifice their life
in order to complete a mission then so
be it that should be considered an honor
however after abandoning his clan tangan
also abandoned those values he
encouraged his wives to value themselves
and their own lives over any mission
which proves that tangan really cares
about his wives and that he values the
sanctity of human life over clan
loyalties he even considered
exterminating his former clan in order
to prevent them from committing more
evil deeds but in the end he just
couldn't bring himself to go through
with killing his own father and brother
after leaving the uzui clan tangent met
oyakatasama and he joined the demon
player corps he climbed the ranks of the
organization until he eventually became
the sound hashira tangen has an immense
amount of respect for oya katasama and
he would be happy to lay down his own
life for the leader of the demon slayers
tangent is such an interesting character
because despite abandoning his clan
which is the biggest sin and the
greatest dishonor for ashinobi he
remained a valiant and honorable man but
he has a completely different code of
honor from his father and brother
instead of valuing his clan above
everything else and trying to make the
clan stronger by any means necessary
tengen values justice and protecting the
innocent he would happily give up his
own life for a noble cause like that one
but he will not fight for a cause that
he doesn't believe in just because that
is what's expected of him by tradition
and the society he grew up in despite
the fact that he is likely considered to
be a traitor and a coward by his clan
members he is actually a truly honorable
and brave warrior for tengen real honor
and real bravery is fighting for a just
cause and he believes that the demon
stairs have the most just cause of all
protecting the innocent from vicious
demons
now let's talk about the insect hashira
shinobu kocho shinobu had an older
sister named kanai and they were both
raised in a loving home by their parents
according to the second demonstrator
fanbook her parents worked in
compounding medicine which i think means
that they mixed medical ingredients
together to create specific medicines
for individual people unfortunately one
day their parents were killed by a demon
this same demon was about to kill
shinobu and kana as well but thankfully
they were rescued by the stone hashira
gyome himejima the tragic loss of their
parents had a profound effect on the two
sisters and they both vowed to become
demons players just like the man who
rescued them they both wanted to become
stronger so that they could protect each
other and so they could spare other
families from suffering the same fate as
their family
kanai eventually became the flower
hashira and shinobu stuck close to her
sister and learned a lot from her one
day while traveling kanai and chinobu
came across a little girl that was being
treated like a slave they freed the girl
from her captor and took her back to the
butterfly mansion where they essentially
adopted her they named the girl kanal
and this is of course the same kanaoh
who is shinobu's current tsuguko or
apprentice some years later when shinobu
was 14 and kanai was 17 kane engaged in
battle against upper moon 2 doma kanae
was mortally wounded during this battle
but doma couldn't finish her off because
the sun was about to come out and so he
decided to flee in chapter 141 we get a
quick flashback to khanna's death and we
see that chinobu arrived on the scene in
time to say goodbye to her sister before
she passes away kannada tells shinobu to
leave the demons air corps so she could
grow old and be happy and so she could
just live out a normal life but shinobu
refuses to quit and instead she vows to
avenge her sister by killing the demon
who killed her after kana's death
shinobu succeeds her sister as the
master of the butterfly estate from that
point forward shinobu becomes even more
determined to destroy the demons and
especially upper moon to doma upon
meeting shinobu tanjiro can tell that
something is off about her otherwise
calm demeanor he can tell that she is
hiding a lot of anger inside of her
tanjiro is indeed correct shinobu has
always been angry her parents were
killed by demons her older sister was
killed by demons and all her apprentices
except for kanel were also killed by
demons these demons killed so many
innocent people they destroyed so many
families and chinobu has been absolutely
furious about it for a very long time
this fury is what drives her to seek
justice at all costs
next up let's talk about shinobu's
savior and the strongest hashira the
stone pillar gyome himejima before he
became a demon slayer gyome was a blind
monk who raised the nine orphans inside
a temple although they didn't have much
they took care of each other and lived
together as a family but one night one
of the children broke the rules of the
temple and didn't return home before
dark that child was captured by a demon
in the forest and was about to be eaten
in order to save himself he made a deal
with the demon if the demon spares his
life he will lead him to the other eight
children at the temple since this area
was known for demon activity gyome had
taken precautions and he burned wisteria
flower incense every night to keep the
demons away
but the orphan who made the deal with
the demon extinguished the incense so
that the demon would be able to enter
the temple four of the children were
taken out instantly and gyome tried to
protect the other four but since he was
blind and not nearly as strong as he is
now three of the children ran off on
their own instead of hiding behind him
and unfortunately those three children
fell victim to the demon when the demon
finally came for gyomei and the final
child gyome decided that he had to fight
back despite being a monk who hated
violence he began fighting the demon
with his bare hands and he just kept on
punching him like a madman until the sun
came out and the demon was killed the
big scar on gyome's forehead came from
this fight against a demon now again
because most people didn't believe in
demons and since the demon's body
disintegrated once the sun came out when
the last surviving child who was only 4
years old tried to explain the situation
to the authorities they thought the
child was telling them that gyome went
crazy and killed all the children so
despite being the one who defeated the
demon and protected the last surviving
child gyome was arrested for murder he
was going to be executed but thankfully
oyakatasama was able to rescue him and
he recruited him into the demon slayer
core since then gyome has been training
relentlessly and he has achieved peak
physical condition he has developed his
physical body to the highest possible
extent and that is why he has earned the
title of the strongest hashira now let's
talk about the youngest hashira the 14
year old missed hashira muichiro tokito
muichiro had a twin brother named
yuichiro and their father was a humble
woodcutter at age 10 they lost their
mother to pneumonia and they tragically
lost their father around the same time
he had actually gone to pick medicinal
herbs for their sick mother during a
storm and he slipped and fell off a
cliff the two 10 year old twins then
suddenly found themselves living alone
as orphans yuichiro was the slightly
older brother and he developed a cynical
outlook on life he thought that their
father was foolish to go out in that
storm in an attempt to help their mother
by that point her condition was already
too severe for some herbs to help her
and if their father had just stayed home
that night then only their mother would
have died instead of both of them
muichiro was more compassionate and
sentimental and he disagreed with his
brother's outlook on life
the following year when the brothers
were around 11 oya katasama's wife came
to visit them at their home she told
them that they were descendants of
legendary swordsmen and that one of
their ancestors was the original breath
of the sun user she wanted the two of
them to become demon slayers but
yuichiro turned her away he did not want
them to risk their own lives trying to
help others because if they did that
then they would just end up like their
father yuichiro simply did not trust the
demonstrators or anyone else and he
refused to foolishly risk his own life
then one night a demon found their home
and attacked them yuichiro was severely
injured and suddenly muichiro snapped he
used his woodcutting axes and every
other tool at his disposal to cut up the
demon and keep him that way until the
sun came out and killed him when he
finally returned to the house muichiro
found his brother praying to the gods
and buddhas to spare muichiro's life
because unlike yuichiro muichiro had a
kind heart and he wanted to help others
yuichiro would ultimately die in his
brother's arms eventually oyakatasama's
wife returned and she was able to heal
muichiro and save his life muichiro then
joined the demonstra corps and the
trauma he experienced blocked out most
memories that he had of his former life
due to his legendary lineage and his
incredible talent muichiro quickly rose
through the ranks of the demonstrators
and he became akhashira only two months
after joining the demon slayer core it
is hard to even imagine what an insane
achievement that is due to the mix of
trauma and memory loss that muichiro
experienced his personality began to
resemble that of his older brother
yuichiro instead of his usual
compassionate and idealistic self he
became more cold and distant he also
felt a deep-seated anger towards the
demons and this anger motivated him to
keep doing his best to hunt them all
down finally let's talk about the wind
hashira sanemi shinazugawa sunemi was
the eldest of seven children which
included his younger brother genya their
father was abusive to his wife and his
children and his mother would often
sacrifice herself in order to shield her
children from her husband's attacks one
day sanemi's father died after being
stabbed by someone he had gotten into a
fight with and sonomy didn't even feel
sorry for his father he felt that his
father got exactly what he deserved
after their father's death sanemy and
genya tried to take responsibility for
taking care of their family since their
mother was kind and compassionate things
seemed to be going well for a while but
then as is so often the case with
demonstrator another tragedy struck one
day when their mother didn't come home
on time sonomy went out to look for her
while genya was in charge of taking care
of the children the household was
attacked by a demon and everyone except
for genya was killed sanemy then showed
up and killed the demon but that demon
turned out to be their mother at first
genya was in shock and he didn't
understand what happened and he lashed
out at sonomy for killing their mother
genya would come to regret this later
when he actually came to terms with what
really happened but by then sunimi had
already abandoned him and dedicated his
life to hunting down demons sonemy
didn't even know that the demon slayers
existed and he didn't even know about
nietzsche and blades so he just used
whatever weapons he could find and he
would find demons trap them and then
burn them in the sunlight he was like a
one-man anti-demon vigilante squad and
his actions were so wild and reckless
that he later thought that he might have
been indirectly trying to end his own
life but he got lucky because he
possessed an extremely rare and special
blood type called marici this blood is
especially intoxicating to demons and it
distracts them and slows them down which
allowed sonemy to get the jump on them
during one of his demon hunts he met an
actual demonstrator named masatka kumeno
and he recruited tsunemi into the demon
slayer core sanomi and masachika became
friends and they both wanted to become
hashira together they defeated a lower
moon one but masatka died during that
battle and so only sanemy was able to go
on to become a hashida the death of
masachika made sanemy angry and he took
that anger out on oyakatasama
felt that as the leader of the
demonstrator core he was just giving out
orders while others were risking their
life on his behalf but to sunimi's
surprise oya katasama took the criticism
gracefully and he even apologized he
explained that his body is simply not
suited for fighting he tried to do it
before but he failed miserably because
of his physical limitations oya katasama
also expresses regret for the loss of
masachika and he knows that sanemy and
masajika were close like brothers oya
katasama's kind face reminds sanemy of
his mother before she became a demon and
the fact that oya katasama goes out of
his way to know and memorize the names
of every single demon sailor who fell in
battle gives sanomi a newfound respect
for the leader of the demon players the
loss of masachika and the will that his
friend left for tsunami also reminds
sanemi that he still has a brother out
there genya and although sanami
continues to be a loose cannon
throughout the series he definitely
calms down a bit and he stops being
completely reckless with his own life
and that is it the full backstory of
every hashira in the demon players story
these were of course the current hashida
that we meet at the beginning of the
story and although we know a bit about
the former hashira like shinjuro sakonji
and jigoro we don't know anything about
them before they became hashira so
because of that it's not really possible
to cover their backstories and of course
kanai's backstory is the same as
shinobus if you're looking for a video
to watch next check out my video that
breaks down the deaths of all the
hashita who died in battle during the
course of the series i will link it in
the description let me know down in the
comments which hashira has the best
backstory in your opinion and who is
your favorite hashira overall including
current and former hashira i look
forward to hearing from you if you guys
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more demonstrate content on the channel
leave a quick like it only takes a
second but it really helps with the
youtube algorithm and if you're new here
or you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications thanks again to the
likewise app for sponsoring this video
check it out link in the description
it's totally free and super useful as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys